[Musique]
dans Saint-Pierre de Rome les Pères
conciliaires ont terminé leurs travaux
pour cette seconde phase de Vatican I
les deux schémas principaux de la
session l'un concernant la liturgie
autre les communications sociales ont
été voté à la presque
unanimité c'est àors que Sa Sainteté
Paul VI a déclaré close la Dee session
du concile au cours d'un discours
retentissant où il annonçait qu'il irait
dès janvier faire un pèlerinage en Terre
sainte aucun souverain pontif ne s'est
jamais rendu en Palestine et ce sera la
première fois depuis un siècle et demi
qu'un Pape quittera la péninsule
italienne ce projet demeurit jusqu'ici
absol secret a eu dans le monde entier
un immense
[Musique]
écho sortant pour une heure de sa
réclusion Jacqueline Kennedy a voulu
malgré son deuil assister à la remise à
Clinton Hill le garde du corps qui tenta
de protéger au péril de sa vie le
président Kennedy au moment de
l'attentat de Dallas de la médaille qui
récompense son héroïsme Clinton Hill
était chargé de la sécurité de la
première dame des États-Unis depu
l'élection de son mari à la
[Musique]
présidence dans une vieille maison de la
banlieue parisienne c'est un rendez-vous
de jeunes curieux rendez-vous de blouse
blanche comme en ont aujourd'hui en
France des centaines de jeunes gens
saisis par la passion des fusées sous le
vocable ambitieux de club spatial
international des étudiants de jeunes
ingénieurs de simple passionnés se sont
retrouvés aux heures de loisirs pour
ajouter un élément à leur œuvre commune
une fusée qu'ils ont ont appelé Europe
alpha comme eux un peu partout des
jeunes gens font les mêmes gestes avec
le même désir construire une fusée dont
le lancement un jour témoignera de leurs
compétences juvéniles Europe alpha
Gérard Venturini nous l'a décrit le
propulseur c'est un c'est un appareil
que nous avons conçu entièrement il est
il est donc entièrement nouveau et nous
ne savons pas exactement la façon don
dont les dans les essais se passeront et
c'est pour ça que cela nécessitera très
certainement un essais statique
préalablement
les essais statiques du propulseur de
leur invention ont eu lieu avec comme il
convenait toutes les précautions
d'usage minute émouvant il en est où les
espoirs de plusieurs mois étaient
engagés résultat décevant mais la
déception n'a pas duré mais dit-moi
s'intéresseon en hautlieu à vos travaux
bien écoutez
pour l'instant nous ne sommes pas
considérés avec beaucoup de de sérieux
étant donné que nos moyens sont
extrêmement limités mais le Centre
national d'études spatial quand même
nous accorde quelques crédits et je
pense que avec son accord par la suite
nous pourrons réaliser certaines choses
dans le domaine spatial évidemment vous
n'avez pas été pressenti par des nations
étrangères non pas encore non merci
rendez-vous donc au jourg et nos jeunes
fon Brown de banlieu viennent de se
retrouver avec d'autres passionnés sur
le terrain de la courtine Europe alpha
avec sa passagère est maintenant muni
d'un propulseur fourni par le Centre
d'étude spatial tous les espoirs sont
permis et après dira-t-on et bien c'est
ainsi que des vocations naissent et
[Musique]
grandissent à une époque où les
sous-marins sont devenus autant de
rampes de lancement possible de fusée la
nécessité s'est fait sentir de
multiplier les sous-marins chass ur de
sous-marin c'est à cet objectif que
répond le deuxème submersible atomique
britannique entièrement fabriqué en
Angleterre même le réacteur cette fois
est anglais il pourra rester de mois en
plongé comme sa mission de chasse
[Musique]
l'exige aux États-Unis dans le même
temps on a expérimenté l'arme idéale
dont il conviendra de doter de tel
bâtiment ce sont des tubes lorpis
classiques qu'on utilisera lorsqu'un
sous-marin ennemi aura été localisé pour
lancer cette arme nouvelle une fusée de
2 tonnes à tête
nucléaire mais contrairement au torpill
d'hier un moteur propulsera l'engin hors
de l'eau et lorsqu'il se sera détaché la
tête nucléaire poursuivra sa route par
autoguidage vers sa proie
[Musique]
sous-marine
rien ici qui ne soit pas d'Auvergne de
l'enseigne au jambon du chantur client
et cependant nous sommes à Paris mais
Paris ne peutil pas compter comme le 8e
département du Massif central et lesir
de Cab rêver du pays il sont 500000 dans
l'agglomération parisienne 500000 don le
fief le plus connu tourne autour de la
base le quartier général couvre toute
une partie du 11e
arrondissement
un cercle dont le centre serait la place
Voltaire avec en plus deux têtes de pont
situé autour des gare m au pays la gare
de Lon et la gareosterlit ainsi ils sont
plus près de leur clocher c'est en effet
par là qu'ils sont tous arriv par là
qu'ils repartiront tous car l' vernia
retourne en général mourir chez lui en
général vernia d'hier était BIA vin et
charbon c'était son blason qui connu ses
boutiques sans éclat aujourd'hui en voie
de disparition puisque de 2500 avant la
guerre elles ne sont plus que la moitié
et chaque année il en disparaît
régulièrement une cinquantaine le Bouat
disparaissant l'Auvergne s'est
reconverti on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
elle monopolise à 98 % les débits de
tabac 90 % des café et des restaurants
et 50 % des hôtels sont aussi des fief
au vermia ainsi dans tous les quartiers
de Paris et dans tous les café célèbre
vous atterrirez infailliblement à la
terrasse d'un oververnia que ce soit le
café de fleur la coup
le Pavillon Dauphine chez lip et chez
Dupont et certaines brasseries d'
alacienne ont aussi le cœur au
vernia retournons à la galoche où la
cabrette fait rêver tous ses exilés du
pays natal le pays dont ils sont fiers
et dont de temps en temps il compte les
gloires
versorix la
faillette Michel de l'hôpital
bless Pascal esprit de génie Paul dou
qui devint président de la République
Jean Verdier archevêque de Paris il pens
à George Pompidou à Valérie giscardestin
à Jul
romain à Fernand Ren et qui fait chanter
la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui c'est une liste
encourageante que sans doute se répète
le jeune auvernia qui débarque avec deux
chemise et un complet dans sa petite
valise rassurez-vous ce jeune homme
n'est pas perdu il sait où il va car le
ber le Paris à son
journal et nul doute que sa petite
annonce trouvera sa destination on le
retrouvera garçon de comptoir chez un de
ses
compatriotes le même journal annoncera
plus tard son mariage avec la fille d'un
auvernia et ses premiers succès
commerciaux étape par étape
d'agrandissement en agrandissement le
journal le suivra dans son
[Musique]
ascension on les rrouve trouvera un peu
vieilli sans doute mais satisfait d'une
réussite qu'ils auront gagné à force de
travail de patience et d'économie plus
tard fort unee fête il rendra son
tablier et transmettra le flambeau à un
compatriote bien entendu et par l'une
des deux gares ils reprendront le chemin
du pays en vagon lit cette fois
maintenant ils vont vieillir et ils ne
penseront plus à
[Musique]
Paris